AARON SIDFORD: Thank you for the introduction.
Hi, everyone.
I am Aaron Sidford.
I am one of the many organizers
of this current program
happening on data structures
and optimization for algorithm
design or something like that.
So I'm fortunate to be organized
in the program along with Alina
Ene, Monica Henzinger,
Yin Tat Lee, and Jelani.
And I guess in the
three minutes I have--
I thought I had five minutes--
I'm just going to give you
a very brief sense of what
this program is on data
structures and optimization
for fast algorithms.
So there's a number
of different things
that's motivating this program,
happening this quarter.
One of the key motivations
underneath this program
happening is a
number of advances
that have happened in the last
few years in algorithm design.
So for a wide range of our
fundamental, foundational,
algorithmic, and
optimization problems,
like convex programming,
linear system solving,
analyzing [? random ?]
[? walks ?] in Markov chains,
computing flows and graphs,
optimizing Markov decision
processes, for this broad range
of some of our foundational
algorithmic and
optimization tasks,
there's been breakthrough after
breakthrough, in many cases,
improving runtimes that haven't
seen improvements for decades,
and in some cases,
for the first time,
achieving some of these Holy
Grail results of provably
solving these problems in nearly
linear or almost linear time.
And what's I think particularly
exciting about these results,
beyond just they've been the
pursuit of algorithm design
for decades, is the wide
range of tools and techniques
that have underlying
these advances.
So many of these results, they
use different optimization
methods like gradient descent,
interior point methods,
and multiplicative weights.
They use a variety
of data structures
to then implement these
optimization methods
efficiently, different
sorts of ways
of maintaining decompositions
of large graphs, different ways
of processing matrices to
get information out of them
efficiently.
And then in enabling
those data structures,
they also use a variety
of sketching techniques,
maybe some techniques we
think of for processing
very large data sets or working
in low memory and in low space.
And there's a number of
rich, interesting ways
these tools and techniques
have been combined.
So some of these
results, they work
by using the optimization method
to reduce the optimization
problem to a data structure
problem that is then solved
using sketching techniques.
Some of these works use
the optimization methods
that solve these problems
dynamizing the optimization
method or using the
optimization theory to reduce
dynamic problems to solving
sequence of static optimization
problems.
And given all these
rich connections,
and has been discussed, one of
the many roles of the program
and tying together researchers
from a variety of areas,
the goal of the program is we
have researchers and experts
in all these different areas of
data structures, optimization,
sketching, and we're
bringing them together
towards getting
faster algorithms.
The goal is to find
new connections
between these areas, get new
advancements, more efficient
algorithms, hopefully open the
door to more areas of research
and push all the
amazing research that's
already happening.
We've already had three
workshops complete.
We have one last one scheduled.
If you're interested
in the program,
you can check out the
videos from the workshops
that have already happened.
And I think I'm out of time.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]